nobody takes a photo like this gentleman
right here you have some of the best
publicity stills ever I just love your
photos let's take a look let's take a
walk through there you are
nobody does that when they go to appear
by the way it looks like you're marking
your territory then let's move on here
that's a happy guy by his pool you're
always happy
I like that too let's keep going what's
happening what's happening here sounds
like these women found you in the lost
and found who lost his John Claude Van
Damme whoa like taking that walk down
memory lane excuse me yeah it was great
great search like a life go by yeah life
go fast yeah go fast yeah you you of
course a national treasure in Belgium
they have a statue you have a statue yes
many people can say that that's I think
we have a photograph of it right here
there's your statue yeah in Belgium do
you when you go to Belgium do you look
after your statue do you go and make
sure that it's okay do you do you take
care of it are you ever worried that
maybe there's some pigeon [ __ ] on it
you've got to take you don't I mean that
would be something to worry about but
you're right so I come at night late at
night with a bucket you kids sure you
can my statue I mean nobody will clean
it yeah
you